then the Greenlaw author of the lobster
chronicles you say that the world's most
dangerous profession is fishing why now
I think mostly it's because of bad
weather
you're definitely you know out in the
weather especially sword fishing I've
done lobstering and sword fishing all
different types of fishing but fatigue
is often a factor but I think bad
weather is the biggest the biggest
factor how many friends have you lost
over the years from fishing close
friends I've lost nearly a dozen but
there's this real sort of fraternity
among fishermen when you hear about
someone going down or being lost at sea
or being killed aboard a boat you may
not know them but you feel you do feel
some connection how long have you been
fishing I've been fishing since I was 19
years old and I'm 41 now so 21 years
why do you fish I am passionate about
fishing and people always ask me what do
you like about it I like the way I feel
when I'm at sea so when you were 19
where did it all start I started as a
cook on a sword fishing boat and at the
time it was a summer job to help pay my
way through college where'd you go to
college I went to Colby College in
Waterville Maine and this book called
the lobster chronicles is what book for
you book number two what was book number
one and when did it come out book number
one was the hungry ocean and it was
published in 1999 about sword fishing
the the book is structured around a
thirty-day sword fishing trip to the
Grand Banks of Newfoundland and what's
your relationship with the whole perfect
storm movie and the perfect storm story
and Sebastian Junger
well I suppose most people if they've
ever heard of Linda Greenlaw recognized
my name as the woman who survived the
perfect storm I was the captain of the
Andrea Gail's sister ship the Hannah
Boden so most people make the perfect
storm connection right you know very
quickly I was running that sword fishing
boat the last six years that I sword
fished and because of the book people I
was asking how did the perfect storm
change your life the weather event
itself didn't really change my life a
great deal but the book by Sebastian
Junger changed my life from fishing to
writing mice I started because of the
very generous portrayal of me in that
book started getting a lot of attention
from the media and got some attention
from publishers what year did you start
the writing thing then it took me one
year to write my first book so I started
in 1998 and finished in 1999 now when we
record this we're recording this in
August your books number two on the New
York Times bestseller list did you ever
think that would happen no I have been
so surprised and of course thrilled why
why do you think this is happening I
have a theory that I think people are
generally really interested in reading
nonfiction written by someone who has
done what they're talking about because
I get so many people coming up to me
asking me to sign a book and saying they
really they felt like they were on the
boat with me and they feel that it's a
very genuine story and people seem to
find it very refreshing now I looked at
your book to her its enormous the number
of play how many places are you going my
original tour was supposed to be two
months taking me to sixty bookstores and
now the tour is being extended to a
foliage tour so I'm gonna go home for a
little while in September and then go
back on tour for maybe just a couple of
weeks in October how are your crowds
they've been great I've been again very
surprised not so much at the crowds in
Maine now when I'm in Maine it's my home
state I was anticipating some really
nice support and I've gotten that but
I've been them really genuinely pleased
with the support that I've gotten
outside of Maine why do you think
they're all coming out to the bookstores
in oh and what are the first couple
questions they always ask you I think
people are genuinely interested in
meeting fishermen because that's not
really not everybody knows a commercial
fisherman so people are genuinely
interested in that the first couple of
questions people are usually interested
how did you go from college to fishing
for a career and how did you go from
fishing to writing stern Fabio I'll just
grab that one out of the Mellie your
book
what's that chapter about stern Fabio is
an endearment almost for a young man who
showed up on the island where I live
looking for work asked me for a job I
did
really need a stern man which is a
person who works in the stern of a
lobster boat because my dad works for me
but this this kid was so persistent and
you know you don't even have to pay me I
really want to try it it's been my
lifelong dream to go fishing that I
immediately liked him he is a nice nice
kid and took him fishing and through the
course of maybe a month of having him
work for me I discovered some things
about him that weren't that good and so
he fooled me
which was not the most pleasant thing
but how did he fool you well I really
liked him and I thought he was a great
hard worker and a nice person and in the
end it turned out that he wasn't such a
nice person and he ended up not showing
up for work which was bad because I
liked it but I wanted to wait you know
he's probably just late we'll wait a
little longer at the dock to see if he
shows up and then to just be like stood
up it's sort of hurtful to really sort
of put confidence in someone and hire
them and and have them be on your boat
and then have them be a no-show
why the name Stern Fabio well he was
very handsome how old was he
young I'd say he was early 20s where'd
he go where'd he end up well I don't
know he disappeared from the island he
ended up he he went ashore to do
something and you end up stealing my
vehicle that I have on the mainland and
disappeared for a couple of days and
word got to him that I was not very
happy and he never he never showed back
up to work after that so I haven't seen
him where is the island it's Isla ho and
it is in Penobscot Bay seven miles off
the mainland coast of Maine ok we need
more clothes to what how do you get
there ok the closest mainland is
Stonington Maine and to get to the
island you either have to have your own
boat or travel by mail boat which is
privately owned boat that has a contract
for the Postal Service to bring the mail
back and forth from the island so it's
not the easiest place to get to it's a
beautiful island is physically beautiful
that people are great Islanders are I
say quirky and I made that in a very
nice way where were a little bit of an
odd group is there somebody on the
island named Rita in actuality there was
someone on the island named Rita
used her real name and people always ask
about Rita and you know the way she got
into my book I was 2/3 of the way
through the writing process in my editor
called me I said Linda you can't love
everyone you know you're gonna have no
credibility here you're not writing a
fairy tale isn't there anyone out there
that you genuinely dislike and I said oh
yes there is and I wrote more than he
cared to hear about about this character
Rita who was she she was one of my
closest neighbors for two years the
first two years that I was back on the
island and she was a major nuisance she
would come over uninvited let herself in
even if I wasn't home she'd be in my
house using the telephone without
permission and you know ask her time and
time again please you know don't come in
if I'm not home we don't lock our doors
on the island we don't lock our vehicles
we don't take keys out of anything so to
have somebody very intrusive
it was hard sort of hard to deal with
highlanders are very non-controversial
you know we don't like conflict so it's
easier just to allow somebody to abuse
you or use you badly than it is to
actually say something so it's just
easier to just say oh you know whatever
it's Rita whatever happened to her she
moved off the island less than a year
ago and she now lives on the mainland
I'm sure she's um annoying somebody
helps now what do people do in
situations like that on an island where
you're very close for the most part
nobody says anything nobody wants to
confront anybody it's just easier to
sort of sweep it under the rug or ignore
it something could be driving you nuts
but you certainly would never want to
make waves or mention it to someone it
is such a small close-knit community
that most everyone is aware of what's
going on but things just aren't aren't
talked about the main reason that we
wanted you to do this program was a kind
of a sub theme in your book it's not
prominent but it's a sub theme and that
is regulation and the law that has
something to say about fishing and
lobstering and I made a bunch of notes
about things that directly affect you
know by they from the state standpoint
the lobster
pot itself has the laws that tell you
what you have to do how you make it up
sure there is a size restriction and
there are these escape vents for small
lobsters to get out of that it's all you
know very legal there are some real
restrictions on what you can put in the
water to try and catch a lobster who
tells you that the the lobster has to be
a certain size the state of Maine there
are federal regulations and there are
Maine state regulations but I'm governed
by the state of Maine so if someone
wants to be a lobster fisherman how do
they start really hard to start right
now because there's a moratorium on all
Maine State lobster fishing licenses
young guy wants to go lobster and forget
it you can't just apply to the state of
Maine and get a license that's
relatively new maybe the last four or
five years that sets come into effect so
now you'd have to be an apprentice for I
think it's three years and do a lot of
paperwork and have marine patrol people
sign off on all these days that you have
spent as an apprentice before you can
actually go lobster yourself do you have
a license I do I have a Maine state
license I've had it since I was a kid
and I fortunately renewed it every year
even when I was sword fishing I kept my
Maine State lobster license so when I
decided to go lobstering I was all set
what's it cost a year to have a Maine
State lobster license it's not a lot of
money the bligh since that I have is
like two hundred and seventeen dollars
or something like that for the season
for a year so it's a it's not a great
deal of money
how many lobstermen are there in the
state of Maine
good question thousands I wish I had the
exact number thousands there are so many
people on the coast of Maine who make
their only living or most of their
income catching lobsters how many women
are there not all that many there are a
few who have their own boats like myself
and there are more and more Stern Stern
men or women that work in the Stern's of
boats for a father or a boyfriend or an
uncle why do you need a stern man well
you can get a lot more done with a stern
it's just much easier you can haul more
gear with some help if somebody's in the
stern of the boat picking the traps are
taking the lobsters out rebaiting the
traps baiting the bags which is a mesh
bag that we put the bait in
it just goes a lot better it's it's
safer to have a stern man with you
fishing alone is dangerous if something
happens you go overboard there's nobody
there to at least knock the boat out of
gear you say that lobstermen are
undemocratic by nature I think fishermen
in general are undemocratic by nature
it's a very self-reliant self-sufficient
group there's not a lot of voting or
committee type solutions to anything
it's about the ultimate being
self-employed what else is controlled
we're talking about the the the where
you catch the lobsters having regulation
what about the boat size the boat size
is not really controlled by your license
not in lobstering and other fisheries it
is because the license the federal
license that you have let's say for
ground fish is all you know by the size
of the boat the license fits lobstering
you can fish any sized boat that you'd
like but there are you know some boats
would definitely be too large and be too
expensive to run them for the intro
lobster fishery and some obviously would
be too small because you couldn't do the
work what about the size of the lobster
size of the lobster in the state of
Maine we have a lobster measure that has
two sides one size measures a lobster to
make sure it's big enough and the other
side of the measure measures it to make
sure it's not too big so we have an
oversized law and an undersized law so
the big lobsters get thrown back as
breeders and the very small lobsters
obviously get thrown back so they have a
chance to reproduce and get to a legal
size what is the size that you can keep
it changes so often I don't know what
the I don't know what the exact
measurement is and I wouldn't dare say
on television because I would be off by
a sixteenth of an inch one way or the
other it's I mean I remember any
something like 3 and 3/4 inch to 5
inches at the you know the body of the
lobster is that right that's the length
of the carapace which is the body it's
measured from the eye socket to where
the end of the body meets the tail why
does it change what is the size change
all the time the size changes as the
lobster molt sir sheds every time a
lobster sheds its old shell and grows a
new shell the lobster grows anywhere
well up to a half an inch every time
this happens does the state change the
the length of that measurement all the
time yes the state does it's been for
the last few years increasing the
measure increases so the lobster has to
be bigger to keep legally which is good
it's good for conservation it's good for
you know the reproduction of the lobster
it keeps the lobster stock healthy who
makes that decision in the state there's
a state there are state agencies that
you know control all the fisheries
there's not like a lobster person but
they're you know Maine marine resources
mostly does that kind of thing do people
look I mean they come around where
you're fishing from the state and check
out your gear and all that stuff yes
there are observers that go on boats to
do studies for the state and there are
also wardens and Marine Patrol people
who you know patrol the area to make
sure everyone's in compliance with the
laws and regulations anybody ever check
you out
sure yes not unusual to be boarded have
a Marine Patrol person come aboard your
boat and measure the lobsters that are
in your tank to make sure that you're
not keeping undersized lobsters make
sure that you're not keeping any egg
bearing female lobsters because it's
illegal to do so so if they find you
doing something wrong what happens
generally if it's the first offense you
may get a fine second or third offense
you could lose your license which would
be devastating for someone trying to pay
bills and raise a family if the only
thing they do is lobster fish if you
lose your license you're out of business
is there a regulation on how many traps
you can have there is a state of Maine
has an 800 trap limit and different
zones in the state of Maine
though the Maine state waters are
chopped up into several zones I fish
Zone C for instance we're allowed 800
traps but there are other zones who have
committed to a smaller trap limit there
are zones who fish 600 traps for
instance as a maximum is there a time of
day that you can fish yes you can only
fish the daylight hours and during the
summer months you can only fish six days
a week Sundays are no fishing why is
that number of different reasons I think
there's no fishing on Sundays to keep
some of the part
out of it or the people that would just
fish in the summer sort of protects the
bottom for the people who are really
making all of their living lobstering
it's harder for someone to put a lot of
gear in the water family have one day a
week to fish which would be Saturday if
you're a weekend fisherman
how many lobsters you allowed to catch
well there's no quota on lobsters
there's only a quota on the number of
traps that you can fish and the hours
that you can fish them as many lobsters
as you can get in those hours in those
days the normal lobster fishing day for
you begins at what time daylight
normally would be when you'd go out and
go to get your bait aboard the boat and
as soon as you can see your first buoy
you should be hauling so what time do
you get up when you have to hit the
first light
I'd say say it's the early part of the
summer it's 4:30 in the morning and you
have to be out there what time to get up
Oh get up around 4:30 5 o'clock go shake
my father out of bed and have some
coffee and go get our bait for the day
normally we try and haul 200 traps a day
and that's not a really long day that's
a pretty comfortable day we'd you know
start early and be done by 2:00 or 3:00
in the afternoon when you say halt what
does that mean when I say halt I mean
actually the act of hauling traps from
the bottom of the ocean getting them
aboard the boat to pick them rebate them
and set them back how heavy is that trap
Oh 30 pounds one lobster trap is around
30 pounds traps come in all different
sizes and configurations they have
bricks in them to weight them to make
sure that they land right side up or
right side down on the bottom of the
ocean and some some people believe in
more bricks some people believe in fewer
bricks I like smaller traps with fewer
bricks because they're just easier for
me to handle physically what's the
largest trap can be in the state 4 feet
long and what is there a smallest it can
be no there's there's no legal limit to
how small a trap can be but it's
advantageous fishing wise to fish the
biggest traps that you can because
there's more room in the trap for
lobsters when did you write the last
last word for this book what was the
date and you remember it was March this
past March March of this year right and
the season you're talking about in here
what you say was a rotten season it was
a rotten season for me I'm writing about
my first lobster season my first year
back to the island because part of the
book is about going home after being
gone for 17 years so I'm reading about
my first season it was a really slow
slow start to the season it did get good
very late but then something happened
that I sort of lost interest in the
season so is it was a terrible season
for me so what year was it exactly hear
that you're writing about oh that would
have been in 1996 so how'd you go about
writing the book how did you recall all
these stories and well most of it was
just from memory I didn't have an
outline I don't keep a diary or a log or
a journal or anything like that but I
had been fishing when I started writing
the book for four years so I knew the
basic okay we have to get the boat in
the water we have to get the gear ready
the gear has to go in the water we're
not gonna catch anything early in this
season hopefully it's gonna get good and
in the season that I write about it did
get good at one point and so I knew you
know the structure of the book is going
to be a lobster season which I was very
familiar with at that point what months
of the year does a lobstermen fish we're
some lobster fishermen in Maine fishing
around we're right where I fish we fish
basically May through December first but
the bulk of the lobsters are caught in
July August September and October and
what happens in those other months what
are you catching then and what years
what months are they the shredders where
they're not full Lobster not full meat
basically any time that we're catching a
lot of lobster which is July through
October
we're catching mostly shedders the
softshell lobsters later in the season
and earlier in the season we'd be
catching more hardshell lobsters are the
ones that are very full of meat so what
kind of money do you get paid on a
normal basis for every pound of lobster
that you bring to that you have a coop
we do it we have a call on the island we
call it the island lobster men's
Association I sell to the coop and right
now we're catching mostly shudders
shudders aren't as valuable as a
hardshell the price is around $3 a pound
later in September the price will drop a
little bit more simply because there are
more lobsters being caught and a lot of
the seasonal places that serve lobsters
are closing down that time of year so if
you're a lobster eater in this country
what's the best time to when you go into
a restaurant to order a lobster and
what's the worst time all right well
pound for pound or dollar for pound
you're better off eating a hardshell
lobster I think in the wintertime it's
more expensive than lobsters more
expensive because they're less abundant
because of weather and seasons there
aren't as many people fishing so it's
more expensive but the lobster is really
packed into the shell so you're getting
more for your money
personally I prefer shedders I like the
softshell lobster if I'm eating them
which would be at home I wouldn't eat
one in a restaurant because I make a
real mess I'd rather eat three or four
shutters than one hardshell any day I
think the meat is sweeter they're easier
to get into you don't need all these
tools the last year that you can
remember the statistics on how many
lobsters are caught or pounds of
lobsters are caught in the state of
Maine I couldn't even begin to tell you
well I've seen a figure I've seen two
figures one at 300 million dollars in
lobsters were sold in the last year and
57 million lobsters I was going to say
probably a million pounds would would be
a great season for the state of Maine so
the three million the three million
dollar figure would be no thirty three
hundred million three hundred million
yeah maybe after it's gone through a few
middlemen but not to the fishermen if
the fisherman is getting $3 a pound the
consumer is not getting a big break on
the lobster somebody's making some money
along the way what is the average
lobstermen make in a year
real tough question average a good
lobster fisherman makes a really good
living that he's earning and he's
fishing really hard he's fishing
year-round putting in a lot of hours
hauling a lot of traps and has a big
investment probably has a bigger boat so
he can fish in the winter probably has
the biggest traps his money can buy
bigger traps are more expensive anything
from really good living to real
part-timers kids they go just during the
summer in a skiff hauling by hand a
handful of traps are they allowed to
hold on hand full they don't have a
license
they have to have a license to do so but
there are student licenses and
recreational licenses that people can
get to fish five or ten traps you didn't
give us a figure though in the book you
say that a good lobster man can make
$100,000 a year
sure I'm sure that's not unusual for
some of the highliners but you look very
good lobster fishermen that go really
hard to make yeah I consider that a
really good year's pay on your island
you have a man named Payson
Payson barter he is the best in my
opinion he is the best on the island I
think he works the hardest so if you're
the best what do you do that's the not
so good don't do that makes you a
success well I think when I see Payson
barter whether he's on his boat or
ashore he's always working I hear and
his father have a fish house or a shop
where they work on their gear they're
there constantly
any time of day I go by no matter what
the weather is there there either the
painting buoys are going over line or
rigging new traps it's a constant a
constant job in your book you say your
dad is 71 at the time how old is he now
he's now 72 and your mom had cancer yes
my mom was diagnosed with breast cancer
just about a year ago and three days ago
oh she had doctor's appointments and
this was really good time because it's
the first time in year that she's been
declared cancer-free so very good why
does your dad work with you as your
sternman well he's a retired
suit-and-tie guy and it just happened
quite naturally I was looking for
someone he was very willing to go as a
stern man he couldn't be happier that
I'm on a book tour now because now he's
running my boat and he's hired his own
Stern man so I miss worked out really
well it's been diced eyeballs been a
tomboy and I was had a great
relationship with both my parents but I
was as a kid was sort of a daddy's girl
because I like to do the hunting and the
fishing and the working around the boat
stuff so it's been really nice to go
home and really reconnect with my father
and work with him where were you born I
was born in Connecticut Stamford
Connecticut and lived there for three
months and moved back to Maine with my
parents where I've lived ever since
what's the relationship of your family
to this island my my dad's family is
from the island I am fifth generation on
the island and when did they come there
in the first place the family and under
what circumstances well everyone who
moved to the islands let's say the
settlers of the island were all
fishermen and it was attractive to live
on the island let's say in the 1800s
because it was closer to the fishing
grounds
now that changed somewhere along the way
with the advent a ssin of steam engines
no longer sailing to the fishing grounds
don't need to be as close now because
you know we
these engines also high school education
made it so that high school kids on the
island had to move off the island to go
to high school no high schools on the
island so the island sort of depopulated
between the two things between kids
having to go to school a maine state
regulation and gasoline and steam
engines where did you go to grade school
I went to grade school in Topsham Maine
really small small town there is a
school on the island still there is a
one-room schoolhouse it's one of the few
remaining one-room school houses in the
country and one a very few on these
remote outposts of violence kindergarten
through eighth grade I think there will
be six students in the school this year
and why didn't you go there well I was a
summer kid growing up my father worked
at Bath Iron Works as a shipbuilding
company in Bath Maine so you know dad's
going to work we're going off and going
to school did you go off the island
every day to go to school yeah we lived
off Island I was I was really a summer
kid on the island it is that was my
lifelong dream to live on the island
year-round as a kid I always hated
leaving the island in the fall so Alice
had these great memories of summers on
the island and where did you go to high
school I went to High School in Topsham
Maine at a school named Mount Ayr at
school what did you what were you
interested in in school in those years I
was an excellent student I liked school
I was into sports I was sort of a
weekend fisherman in the summertime with
my parents my parents were always very
avid sports fishermen so I grew up in
the summer is trying to catch anything
that swam or crawled around my home and
I was like school Ivo it was always a
good student and enjoyed that also your
brother's your brother one brother and
two sisters one brother and two sisters
what do they like and what are their
ages compared to yours I have a younger
brother and sister who are twins and
they're eight years younger than I am
and and one older sister who is two
years older than I am
where do they live everyone lives in
Maine we're all in Maine my younger
brother and sister both live in Portland
my older sister lives in Topsham which
is where we went to school as kids and
what do they do for a living my older
sister is a housewife my younger brother
is a marine engineer went to Maine
Maritime Academy shipped out for a while
now works land-based job and my younger
sister is an executive businesswoman and
what do they think of their sister the
fisherman well they don't want to be me
but they you know they're very proud
they're very proud of what I've done and
my accomplishments or whatever I mean
I'm very quick to say that I've also had
a great number of failures but
everything I've done has been hard work
whether it's been success or failure
now what's what have you failed at oh
I'm a real wannabe musician I can't play
anything other things I mean just
fishing in general I've had you know
some really bad years and some really
good years it's all work sometimes it's
sometimes it's very good sometimes
sometimes it's very bad how did you
originally get into sorta fishing I
started as a cook on a sword fishing
boat at the age of 19 as a summer job to
help pay my way through college and that
was out of a place called oars Island
Maine and what got you there though in
the first place why where did you think
that you could be a cook all summer okay
a very good friend of mine high school's
father owned a sword fishing boat so I
knew I knew a fishing I went to school
with kids whose parents were fishermen
and I knew that it was an opportunity I
needed a good paying job to pay q-school
so fishing was good money when I started
how regulated is sword fishing by the
state oh I think any US fisherman
whether it's commercial or recreational
we are the most highly regulated managed
and monitored bunch of fishermen in the
world and that's not to say that that's
bad I know that regulations are needed
I'm a conservationist I like to know
that there's going to be a future in
commercial fishing it's probably the
oldest industry in the world or it may
be the oldest industry in the world the
problem is the regulations are so strict
that a lot of fishermen have been
regulated out or forced out of the
business now the regulations have worked
in many many species of the New England
ground fish fishery is what you hear a
lot about nowadays it's become regulated
by litigation almost you know these
conservationist groups are suing
National Marine Fisheries Service so
it's no longer fishermen and scientists
making rules and trying to do what's
best now it's some other group stepping
in and getting the federal government to
step in and and force laws on fishermen
that are really too too stringent
in my opinion how many how long was is
the sort fishing boat how big is it
the last boat that I ran was a Hannah
Boden and that's a hundred foot boat and
when you were cooking that summer how
big was that how many people worked on
the boat with you when I first started
at the age of 19 I started on a 70 foot
boat and there were six people on the
boat how long would you be out at sea
generally about a month sword fishing
trips we try and time around the moon or
the moat the lunar cycle the fishing is
best from the first quarter through the
last quarter through the full moon and
we try and do our steaming back and
forth in our time at the dock during the
dark moon or the new moon and when you
have a fishing day sort of fishing how
long is the day a fishing day is long on
a sward fishing boat we set the gear at
night because swordfish are nocturnal
they stay feed at night we set the gear
at night we leave it for a few hours
daylight the next morning we start
hauling this 40 mile long piece of line
back aboard the boat now east of
Newfoundland daylight is 3:30 in the
morning so it's a real early start to
the day
it takes most of the daylight hours to
get this 40 miles of gear back onto the
boat so you say you worked as a cook in
the summer time to go to Colby College
what did you study at Colby I studied
English in government why did you do
either one of those well you know at the
age of 19 when you're supposed to be
declaring your major I don't know what I
thought at the age of 19 I thought
attorney sounded good I wanted to be a
lawyer so I thought English and
government that's pretty close to
pre-law and that just sounded like a
good thing to do so that's that's what I
studied I enjoyed both of them but I
knew after I started fishing that I
would not be going to law school by the
way when you told your mother that you
weren't going to be a lawyer and that
you were going to be a Fisher man what
did she do yeah she wasn't very happy
and I write in the lobster chronicles
about one scene in particular it's a
very vivid memory of my mother breaking
like every dish in the house she was so
upset that I was like throwing my
education away wasting my education wait
four years my parents never really gave
up on the law school thing when I
graduated from Colby and told them I was
going fishing now when it was a summer
job it was it was a good idea but you
know I for 17 years I sort of endured
the well-intentioned advice
so parents of you know getting a real
job you're wasting your education and I
do a lot of speaking now since I've
gotten notoriety from the perfect storm
I have an opportunity to speak to
students quite often and one of the
things that I always say is you know my
education has never been wasted
regardless of what my parents thought in
the past I've used every bit of my
education every day whether I've been
fishing or writing or book touring or
interviewing it's never wasted I'm your
education becomes you you'll hear people
say education is a tool now you know
education isn't a tool it's not like a
screwdriver that if you're if you're not
driving a screw it's laying around
dormant you're using it all the time and
it's part of you by the way the scene
though I mean you get the impression
your mother was picking plates off the
you know the shelf and slinging him and
throwing him and everything
oh she was she was throwing them down
onto the floor and breaking them
breaking them yeah she wasn't very happy
normal for your mother to do things like
that or I did well I wouldn't say I was
normal but it wasn't the first
occurrence so I wasn't totally surprised
when it happened
are you like your mother or your father
a little bit of both I supposed why
break dishes oh yeah
and so let's go back to you graduated
from Kobe and what year I graduated in
1983 had you worked on the on the sword
fishing boat during the summers every
year I had at the age of 19 I started I
fished my way through school after I
graduated I started fishing year-round
your night 17 years on a fishing boat
did you buy your own boat at some point
no I didn't I was always like the hired
gun I ran other people's boats for them
very typical there are a lot of there
are very few I should say
owner-operators there are quite a few
people who owned boats and hire other
people to run them give us a range on
what somebody can make as a sword
fisherman I mean just some idea all
right as a person working on deck you
get paid by what you catch you get a
percentage of the catch it's called a
settlement and if you have a very good
trip a person working on debt could make
ten thousand dollars a trip that's ten
thousand dollars a month really good
money for a college kid how many years I
mean how many months a year can you do
that well you can swordfish year-round
but the Grand Banks season
which i think is always the best is May
through October and then some of the US
fleet will travel down to the Caribbean
and fish the winter months are you
regulated on that boat by the government
do you have to have a license - yes you
need a federal a federal license to fish
for swordfish and there are all kinds of
gear regulations enclosed areas where
you can't fish and you know size
restrictions and all kinds of
regulations what kind of money can you
make if you're running the boat if
you're hired to be that well if you're
running the boat generally you'd make
about twice as much as one of the crew
members every month every month but you
know there are so many months that you
would make nothing - there's a thing
that we call a broker which is you know
going for a month and making zero you
know some trips when the fishing is very
poor you're very lucky to pay the
expenses it's an expensive fishery you
leave the dock with forty thousand
dollars of things aboard the boat that
are going to be thrown away during the
trip the bait the food the fuel that
stuff's gone at the end of the trip
forty thousand dollars so what what's
the worst thing that happens when you're
out at sea for 30 days the worst thing
that can happen would be a combination
of bad weather and poor fishing really
hard to deal with one or the other you
can kind of handle like poor fishing if
the weather's nice well you know this is
fun but uh coupled you know bad fishing
and bad weather
really tough to deal with really hard to
stay up and optimistic did you ever
think you were going to lose your life
oh sure I mean I'd be lying to say I've
never been frightened at sea we fish May
through October which is also hurricane
season quite often were a thousand miles
from the dock you're talking now about
lobstering no I'm talking about swords
regime right lob string you're very
close to home less dangerous because
you're not subject to the weather as
much but sword fishing you're very far
from the dock during hurricane season
and yes dangerous so what do you do to
prepare yourself for that you train I'm
not so much training but it's more I
think that good seaman ship is like
ninety percent experienced and ten
percent just a gut feeling I've been on
a boat a long time I know there are
certain things that you do if you know
bad weather is coming ways to secure the
boat and just boat handling skills to
keep the boat as safe as it's going to
be do more people want a swordfish in
there are
for them or the other way I think
nowadays it's the other way around I
think that it's very tough for a boat
owner to get a good captain a qualified
experienced captain there aren't really
many new people because of the
regulations and restrictions it's not
something that young people are jumping
into the money is not there like it used
to be because you can't catch as many
fish because of regulations restrictions
you can't fish year-round you can't fish
this area you can't use that type of
gear it's it's not an industry that
there's a lot of young blood rushing to
is that all regulated by the feds mostly
yes is there a lot of grassing among the
crews and all about how much involvement
there is from the government oh sure
it's disconcerting to be subject to all
of these regulations and seemingly a lot
of them are sort of wasteful I can give
you probably the best example of what I
think a bad regulation is I said earlier
I know regulations are needed you know
it's the fisherman's job to catch the
fish and catch the most the fastest so
regulations are certainly needed to
restrict people but the best example of
a bad regulation that I can give you is
these daily quotas that they have on
ground fish or let's say cod and haddock
no matter what they set the quota at
there will be boats who unintentionally
exceed that daily quota and will be
throwing dead fish overboard that does
nothing for conservation it's very
wasteful it's a bad regulation so what
year did you decide no more sword
fishing I want to go back to the island
I want to start to be a lobstermen in
1996 I decided that I had for a number
of reasons I felt like I'd reached the
top of my game sword fishing I didn't
see any way to really improve my lot I
had the nicest boat I had the best crew
we were doing very well
government regulations were making it
increasingly hard to make a good living
year round and I was ready to go home
I'd been gone for 17 years
late 30s ready ready to go home and
start a family so seemed like a good
time to to move home and still have an
ability to work on the water with
lobster fishing so what happened to the
family well it seems that moving to the
island was not the best idea to
facilitate the family plan as I say in
the lobster chronicles that there are
three single men in residence and two of
them are gay and the other one is my
cousin
a little bit of flack about that but I
but I stand by it you've taken flack
from from a couple other single guys on
the island who know that they aren't my
cousin did you how many names in here
are the actual names I know you say in
your introduction that you've used
synonyms right for the most part they're
all real names I have two composite
characters there George and Tommy of
island boy repairs and I changed one
name Island boy repair was about what
who are those two men two sort of men
who came to the island to vacation fell
in love with the island and decided to
stay and I call them the quintessential
Island suckers because they take and
take and take and they don't really add
much to the island they're the islands
handyman or self-proclaimed handyman who
really seemed to screw more things up
then then they actually fix are they
still on the island yeah these are
composite characters there are people
like that on every Island I've learned
in my book tour everywhere that I go
that people say oh yeah we have people
just like that where I live and you know
these people seem very familiar we have
the same characters in the small town
where I lived now from your just your
survey being on the island how many of
the people that lived there permanently
you say they're 40 they live there
permanently
have read your book I would say most
everyone has read my book at this point
I got to a point right before the book
was available at bookstores being very
nervous about how Islanders would
receive my book and would they see it as
an invasion of privacy so far our
reports are very positive which I
couldn't feel better about obviously I
mean I love the island and I love
Islanders was very nervous about it for
a while until I started getting some
good reports and some good feedback so
if you get in the car and you're at the
main border how many hours is it take
you to drive to Stonington and then what
you have to take the mail boat over
write it from the main border it would
be about a four hour drive to Stonington
and then a 40-minute boat ride and how
often can you go over on the boat ride
this time here there are three boats
that go over a day one in the morning
one midday and one in the afternoon so
it's pretty easy for people to come out
on the morning boat and hike around and
check the island out half of the island
is a Cady National Park so there are a
lot of trails to hike a lot of beautiful
things to see and then get back on the
boat and go back to the mainland
are there places to stay on the island
there is one this the keeper's house
bed-and-breakfast they are booked you
know a year in advance it's a surreal
it's a beautiful place and they do a
great job good food you know beautiful
surroundings they have no trouble
filling the rooms and you say it's
expensive well I think it's expensive I
guess some tiny dollars a night right
I've just come from New York City and
now I think maybe it's not all that
expensive in the summertime is there a
noticeably large increase in number of
people on the island yes we have a big
summer community the population swells
from let's say 40 year-round to maybe
300 in August you know middle of August
probably the busiest time on the island
it's interesting though the summer
community for the most part the summer
people have been coming generation
generation generation a lot of the
summer people have been on the island
longer than some of the year-round
people so there's none of the animosity
or sometimes you know you hear problems
between the year rounders and the summer
people we don't really have that on the
island where I live we get along quite
well you said it at the beginning that
you've lost about 12 friends in this
tell us about the 1983 incident the 1991
the perfect storm no I'm thinking of the
one when the five okay the storm you
know doing the islands okay sorry about
that Charlie I know what you're talking
about yes I was a senior in college and
was watching television one night and
heard this news flash about some young
people from Isla ho being lost at sea
and of course got very concerned those
you know trying to find out what was
going on five young people left the
island to go to see a movie it was in
the early spring they went in a small
outboard to the mainland to go to a
movie and on the way back the boat
capsized from heavy seas and three of
the people died died in the water did
you know them I knew two of them I knew
I knew one of them very well one of them
an acquaintance and the third I didn't
know at all now do you how do you know
now it around when your lobster fishing
whether or not you have a storm problem
you have a it does do you have ways of
keeping in touch with the weather sure
every fisherman has a weather radio at
home and you listen to
the weather before you get aboard the
boat in the morning also the VHF radio
which is what we use for communication
has weather channel on it you can turn
it on any time of day
it's a continuous recording of you know
weather reports so well even with the
radios you know really the best
indicator of what your weather's going
to be is a boat maybe a few miles west
of you those weather moves from west to
east so what they're having you're going
to get weather is not really a factor
where I fished lobstering you know if I
get up in the morning and the weather is
bad I don't have to go I don't have to
get on the boat and go haul traps I can
stay home if the weather is going to be
severe I'm never more than 15 or 20
minutes from the dock so if the weather
does get better looks like it's going to
be bad I can I can scoot in so go back
we were talking about a day and the life
of a lobster man you get up it and you
get out at first light how long do you
stay out on a given day well a long day
would be first light to four o'clock in
the afternoon the nice thing about being
self-employed is at any point in the day
when you feel like you just want to stop
you can as I said my father and I try
and haul 200 traps a day now if things
are going really well
like we aren't tangled up with other
people and you know everything runs
right we don't get any line in the wheel
or the propeller we could be done by two
o'clock how many traps do you have in
the ocean at any given time I have a
license to fish 800 which is the maximum
in the state of Maine but I only have
400 in the water right now
and what's the biggest cut you've had in
any one trap on any given day the
biggest catch in any single trap I had
15 keepers of it so let's say pretty
close to 20 pounds in one trap that's
very unusual how often does that happen
that's only happened once that's only
happened once I say you know in the best
of times for me if I am averaging 3
pounds per trap
that's very good what's the biggest
lobster you ever caught the biggest
lobster ever caught of course we throw
the big lobsters back legally we have
two you know 20 pounds I spent three
winters fishing offshore with a great
with a much bigger boat and the lobsters
sometimes are much bigger offshore so
I've I've caught some some real large
lobsters and what's the worst day you've
had or do you have many days where you
get absolutely no lobster at all well
I've never had a day where I've not
caught a single lobster but I do
the very first time I hauled traps in my
lobstering career just moved home
couldn't wait to go got a bunch of gear
in the water and hauled 417 lobsters the
end of the day we had 17 Lobster it was
a not a good day
what's a gear war gear Wars is what
happens it's something that escalates it
starts off as something so simple as a
newcomer comes to an area lobstering is
very territorial and somebody comes who
is not welcome in an area and it starts
with basically cutting a few of maybe
his buoys off so he knows that's a
warning and to move his gear out of the
area if he retaliates and doesn't know
who to cut he just cuts anybody then
those people who get cut don't know who
did it and they retaliate and cut
anybody before you know everyone is
cutting gear it's very expensive have
you ever been through one I've not been
through a very serious gear where I have
lost year that I suspect has been cut
away and I'd be lying to say I never cut
anybody elses gear right it's never
escalated to a point of what you'd
consider a war is this the kind of thing
that lobst him and don't like to admit
well it's illegal so of course nobody
nobody wants to admit to cutting someone
else's gear there are a lot of people
saying I lost gear and somebody cut me
but you never hear anybody saying I cut
that guy out of the water if you have
400 traps and you have 200 boys like
right
yes that's two traps probably what color
on the boy do you have and who
determines what the color is
each fisherman has their own colored
buoy just so they can distinguish their
own gear from somebody else's the
fisherman this thing picks the color the
buoy color him or herself when you apply
for your license with the state of Maine
part of the application is what color
what's your buoy pattern so mine is
orange yellow and white how much of the
coop were all how many fishermen in your
area belong to the coop that you have on
the island on the island they're about a
dozen fishermen who are sort of
full-time lobster fishermen who belong
to the coop and how much of what they do
is controlled by the state law as far as
fishing yeah just about everything the
way they operate I know you say that
that I mean the way the coop works that
the bonus that you get is usually it
comes out around tax time or after tax
time I mean tell us about the bonus and
how that
right well the bonus that we get is a
result of pounding lobsters or when we
catch lobsters in September and the
price is very low we have a real natural
pound it's called it's a saltwater area
where you can put lobsters to store
while the price is low and then take
them back out in the winter let's say
February March when the price is back
out with when it's back up high and the
extra money or the profit is divvied up
amongst men as the bonus and at a given
time in a normal year how big a bonus is
there anywhere since I've been back to
the island we've had anywhere from a
50-cent per pound bonus to a 75 cent per
pound bonus and it's a bonus not on what
you put into the lobster pound yourself
but it's a bonus on what you have sold
to the coop all season so if you catch
10,000 pounds for the season you're paid
on your 10,000 pounds if it's 50 cents
you get $5,000 and when does that check
usually come to you it usually comes
right in April right at tax time so it's
a real good time to be getting some
money because most fishermen have been
all winter making nothing you have Uncle
Sam to deal with and it's the time of
year when you need to spend some money
to revamp your gear you know you need to
buy paint for the boat and paint for the
buoys and maybe need to buy some new
traps and some new line and and other
things that you need to for the new
season in your book you say I have been
accused all my life of keeping too much
inside and when I read that I thought
for someone has been accused of that you
spent a lot of time talking about
yourself in these books is that been
hard yeah though the lobster Chronicles
was such a difficult book to write
because it is so personal really
difficult to write about yourself and
really difficult to write about
relationships with family and community
and so difficult to articulate this some
very deep and profound love of place it
was a real tough book to write okay what
about this about yourself you tell us in
there you want to be married you want to
have children right I do and you know
people are sometimes a little surprised
that they can't believe you're so candid
about your personal life and your
desires to get marry and have children I
think well you know it's not something
I'm ashamed of I'm not you know ashamed
to say yeah you know I'd like to have a
very traditional family so how you going
to do this if you're on the island
there's only got much choice there I
mean it helped you bid on this book to
her well book tour has been interesting
because you know I get a few cards from
people or generally if I go into a
bookstore to do a signing one of the
women who works in the store say oh you
know I've got a guy to introduce you to
but you know it's not really you really
get a chance to meet anybody on book
tour for more than five minutes because
it's you know you're here and then
you're gone to the next place so it's
that's not not the best way to meet
somebody I don't think so what's next
after this book is your life going to
change again two successful best-selling
books I've signed a contract to write a
third book so I know what my immediate
future will be when I'm done with my
book tour I'm going home to finish the
lobster season when the lobster season
is over I'm gonna start writing a third
book I would like to write a novel about
well I don't have a plot but whatever I
write all I know about is fishing and
boats and islands so I have a setting
and that's about it why a novel I am so
sick of writing in the first person I am
so sick of Linda Greenlaw I think it
might be refreshing to not have to
really feel compelled to stick to the
truth and wonder how people are gonna
feel about what you're saying about them
I think it might be a relief to maybe
let my imagination play a bigger role in
in my writing how did it work after your
first book came out and by the way can
folks still buy it is it still in the
stores yes yes it is it's available in
paperback and it's called the hungry
ocean and then how did the second book
come about how did it work with your
agent how did it work with the book
publisher right well because the first
book did well I was approached by the
same publisher Hyperion to write a
second book and I said yeah you know I'd
like to write a novel and they said no
we would like for you to write another
nonfiction so they gave me a two-book
deal which was lobster chronicles first
and third book hopefully to be something
of my choice
this is private but are you gonna make a
lot of money off this book well you know
my pipe dream is to make enough money
through my books that I can fish just
because I want to and not because I have
to pay bills certainly the books have
been successful I hope to make a lot of
money with them how many of these are
out there in circulation right now your
books well I think the last report I
heard was that we were up to 180
five thousand in print how many are
circulating I don't know and the
timetable on your next book you have to
have that done well I started this tour
in New York one month ago
and I signed a contract to extend my
deadline so apparently I've already
missed a deadline I haven't even written
one word yet it took me longer to write
the lobster chronicles than anybody
anticipated so I'd like to think that I
can get a major portion of that done
this winter how did you how did you
write it where did you write it I write
longhand in a notebook and make all my
correction Corrections on the paper you
know arrows and things crossed out and
pages stuck in and when I get a section
or a chapter to a point where I think I
am NOT going to be able to make it any
better I take the time to type it in to
the computer I'm very slow typing that's
the last edit that I do of something
before I send it to my editor send it to
the editor and within two or three days
I get a call from him saying this is
good that's not more of this less of
that keep going don't go back and
rewrite just keep going and I basically
got through both of my books with that
process so where did you write it
I wrote the lobster chronicles I wrote
most of it on Isla Howe I wrote a little
bit in Portland Maine had an apartment
in Portland for a while and wrote a
little bit there by the way you're
saying Isla Howe and for those that have
never seen this it's is Ellie and then a
new word au and then a new word capital
H a UT that's right how do you get from
what looks like anything but Isla ho to
Isla ho well what's it mean it means
High Island it's French island of
Heights which is a very mountainous
island it's a first island that you see
from offshore because it is so high
many people pronounce it Allah ho and
I've heard so many different
pronunciations the year-round local
population says Isla ho so what's it
like living on an island I like it but
it's not for everyone it's it's a tough
existence I think there are a lot of
analogies that can be drawn between
Islanders and fishermen you need to be
self-sufficient self-reliant you need to
not have a problem spending a lot of
time alone and do you have any time ever
being alone I enjoy my time alone I also
learned through trying to write on the
island my first winter thinking
this would be great no distraction you
know I'll just right right right right
right I'll get this whole book done I've
learned that you do need some
stimulation from the outside you do need
communication with people or I do anyway
when you live on the island what about
things simple things like newspapers do
you get to get any do you watch
television
can you hear radio from where you are we
can hear radio we have no local
newspaper there's no newspaper delivery
service to the island some people now
have satellite dishes so they they're
able to see television you know whenever
they want and see whatever they want
most people have computers and there
there are phone lines so you can have
internet access I think the things that
are tough aren't like we have the
technological advances things that are
tough are you know there are no service
people on the island so if you need a
plumber or an electrician you know
you're on your own or try and get one
from the mainland to come out it's tough
so your boat is how long again how big
is it my lobster boat is 35 feet long
the name Duffy and Duffy is a
manufacturer of the boat and the name of
the boat is the Maddy Belle named after
my grandmother and your grandmother on
what side and what was her full name
yeah my dad's mother who is Maddy Belle
Robinson and there is a Robinson name on
the island isn't there somewhere yes
there is the there's a Robinson's point
which is where the lighthouse is so when
you go out fishing do you have a cell
phone now I do not I'm a dinosaur I'm
like one of the only people probably on
the planet who does not own a cell phone
but I have a VHF radio and can you talk
to the ground can you go talk to your
your mother or whatever but I can we
have a handheld VHF at home that if my
mother needs to get in touch with my dad
and or I she could call us on the radio
so how long do you think your father
will continue being your stern man well
I hope a long time I really I really do
enjoy working with my dad he's 72 now
but he's in great shape he loves working
everyday he can work me under the table
so I'm sure he'll be going strong for
some time when did he retire from his
other job and at Bath Iron Works at the
age of 65 he retired normal retirement
job the book is the lobster chronicles
our guest is Linda Greenlaw
and the book looks like this his picture
on the cover was taken where that was
taken aboard my boat right in front of
the lighthouse fishing off isla ho
thank you very much for joining us thank
you